a shocking new survey reveals just how
widespread gun violence is in this
country just listen to these numbers
nearly one in five adults one in five
say they have had a family member killed
with a gun that's according to a new
survey from kff for black Americans that
statistic is even worse one in three and
eighty four percent of adults say they
have taken at least one precaution to
try to protect themselves or their
families from gun violence and that is
not the only disturbing number in this
survey there is more Nikki Batiste as it
details
there's only so many times you can walk
into a room
and tell someone they're not coming home
tomorrow
and it just breaks your heart Louisville
trauma surgeon Jason Smith says he has
seen and had enough I'm weary he's not
the only one seeing the effects of gun
violence firsthand in a new survey on
the impact of gun violence kff found
that 54 of adults said they have or a
family member has experienced a
gun-related incident such as being
threatened with a gun or having a family
member killed by a gun including by
Suicide Ashley kurzinger was one of the
survey's lead authors to her it's
personal my sister was accidentally shot
in the back so thankful that she
survived but I can tell you firsthand
it's impacted my family hers and so many
others from mass shootings at concerts
movie theaters places of worship
supermarkets schools and inside the
workplace it's a toll that keeps melting
the survey found 15 percent of people
have avoided religious services or
celebrations 20 percent have changed or
considered changing their child's school
and 35 percent have avoided large crowds
because of the possibility of gun
violence I think a lot of attention is
being paid to victims immediately
following the shooting but I think what
the survey shows is that there's a long
tail that follows these victims and
their families
foreign
also showed gun violence
disproportionately affects people of
color and safe gun storage is also an
issue according to the results nearly
half of parents say they have a gun in
their home about one-third of those
Firearms are either loaded or stored in
an unlocked location so this is a really
important reminder if you do not own a
firearm particularly if you have
children children yes store them safely
yeah well because you know Kaiser Family
Foundation reports that gun violence is
now the number one cause of death for
teens and for children in this country
surpassing motor vehicle deaths yeah yes
and that's relatively new and for other
countries you know they also have of
issues with mental health they have
issues with crime that we struggle with
also but they're no more than fifth in
terms of cause of death among children
so something is different with What's
Happening Here than compared to all of
our peers around the world yes a
reminder you know we hear about mass
shootings on the news but gun violence
is affecting so people every day and
once like your family it affects you for
a long time like she said it has a very
long tail we're not even really talking
about Nashville the way we used to
they're still grieving there they're
still grieving in Uvalde they're still
grieving in Buffalo and we go on to the
next thing it's not right and it's
extremely frustrating Nikki thank you
very much